[Music]
oh
i thought you said you're dead did not
bat
that is not my talk
yes a classic inspector clue so moment
and a nod to dad joke enthusiasts
everywhere it's also a lead-in to
today's la vegas now segment sponsored
by eric palacios and associates today we
talked to eric about how you could be on
the hook legally if your dog bites
someone
all right so we're talking doggies today
yeah um
this started because uh there were some
stray dogs in my neighborhood
they looked menacing i took them in they
turned out they were pretty nice okay it
made me think oh what is the liability
if my dog were to escape and go bite
someone or cause treatment
no great question
so what what is what liability do i have
as a dog owner if my dog gets out and
causes damage or bites someone or
another dog
uh great question if uh your dog has a
propensity uh to do harm or to to bite
or is aggressive then generally
you're liable right off the bat because
you should have known that he would uh
it would bite somebody uh and you should
have had them on a leash
or a fence to to protect those uh other
than your family
if your dog is
calm and has never shown any type of
aggressive behavior and then bite
somebody uh generally on the first bite
uh you're not uh liable for that as long
as you haven't been negligent in any
other way
so as a homeowner or renters insurance
does that cover that type of thing
it generally does uh
some breeds you have to specifically
notify your homeowner's insurance you
should always notify them of the pets
you have in the house regardless but
some particular breeds because they
are more aggressive or
prone to to bite or hurt people
then you have to notify
your homeowner's insurance for them to
cover you
in the event something happens and then
if the dog has
bitten or caused damage in the past
sometimes you need a separate policy
to cover yourself for that so then is
there a legal definition of a
quote-unquote vicious dog
there is there's a few definitions one
uh is a dangerous dog and a dangerous
one is one that has uh
caused harm or or acted in an aggressive
manner at least twice in the last 18
months
without being provoked or without being
in pain obviously if a dog is provoked
they're going to protect themselves or
if a dog is in pain sometimes you're
trying to pick it up take it to the vet
move it you know they'll also bite just
because of their physical uh condition
or illness or pain
and uh three if your dog was off leash
or got out of the house
so if these three things uh happen then
your dog can be considered uh dangerous
now a vicious dog is one that has
already been labeled as dangerous and
then continues to act in a menacing uh
manner or continues to bite or has
caused death or severe bodily harm so um
sometimes you know we'll see a a dog
that
will attack especially if it's a young
child uh and cause so much damage or
even their death uh that would be uh
classified immediately as a vicious dog
knowing your dog is the key to avoiding
problems
that's it
for more information you can give eric
palacios and associates a call that
number on your screen
go to their 702-444-7777 at
ericpalacioslaw.com
las vegas now will be